I am a recovering perfectionist when you
start it won't be the perfect first step
the most important thing is that you
started and you did something you have
to decide to be resourceful that you're
capable of more as long as you think
that way you'll stay that way
[Music]
[Applause]
I am a recovering perfectionist so I
lost a 40 million dollar deal when I was
22 and I spent the whole summer I had my
biotech software company that was
struggling at the beginning we found
their way through we started making
success I could go down that path if you
guys want to talk about it but we're
looking at selling our business getting
acquired and I spent the whole summer
working on this proposal I did all the
research and it's like perfect like I
stain day and you know day in day out
working on it
perfect proposal we get to three months
done gonna go talk to the company they
see it like no I'm interested like what
do you mean it's perfect like this just
makes sense right like we fade into your
company it's perfect it's it no not
interested it's like oh I'm screwed now
now what do I do
so I try to find another deal and end up
find another company that was looking at
my biggest competitor and they said yeah
we want to get into your space so we
started talking to them and then it
ended up being between us and my biggest
competitor and they said you know what I
love you we love you we love your
company we love you as people as humans
but we have to make a decision quickly
and we've already done so much due
diligence with these other guys that
we're gonna go with them instead of you
if you came earlier maybe we would have
had a shot but like it's just we need to
go fast and they bought that company for
40 million dollars now if I just went
and started talking them earlier what
I've got the deal I don't know you don't
know right but a 50% chance you know I'm
40 million dollars that's decent odds
you know and so I had to get out of my
own way and say you know what I need to
get comfortable with releasing imperfect
things and so I always start things off
super low just myself just getting
started when I started my Instagram live
stuff if you guys ever saw my morning
show when I was back in Toronto I've had
guests on and it was just me and my cell
phone and a tripod let's go let's start
I came up with that idea after the LA
trip after my four days of killing
myself I'm on the airplane home and I'm
thinking I mean I want to do this more
but in a healthy way so how do I do it
how would I do an Instagram I
morning show I bring a local
entrepreneur from my city on and I help
them for an hour and we film it so that
other people can learn from it too and
here's the thing so I'm on the flight
deciding this is what I want to do I'm
I'm in air coming home and I notice I'm
losing certainty in that idea I'm 100%
certain
and then I'm 95 and then I'm 90 I'm
gonna 85 as I get further and further
away as I get closer and closer to home
I become less certain and less
interested in doing that thing so I have
to decide okay we got to make this
happen before I check out right because
it's the right thing I believe the
decisions you make when you're feeling
bold or actually the best things for you
and then your head spends time talking
down from those big ideas right so I'm
in the moment and feeling I'm feeling
great I make a decision I went to an
Instagram live show every day
that's actually the best thing for me
and then my head will talk me down from
it and find reasons why I can't do it so
while I'm on my flight home I start
committing to it so I tell my team guys
I'm starting a new morning show here we
go we're gonna do it because I don't
just match it have two hours open every
day of the week in my business so it
impacts people's schedules and they'll
work around it we made it we made it fit
but I told them guys were starting this
new morning show I then booked the first
five guests for my show myself because I
wanted to have somebody booked Danny
back there messaging back great when do
we start and it was it was Friday when I
was flying home Monday like we start
ASAP we start Monday
and so I hard committed myself and I
hate disappointing people so I have to
follow through on it and the funny thing
is when I showed up in for that first
day in Toronto on the Monday when I got
back home I didn't want to do it if you
had told me Evan you should do an
Instagram live morning show and help an
entrepreneur out I say yeah I like it
but two hours was setup and teardown and
getting back and it's just not a good
use of my time
I was already checked out but I had
committed so I did it and it was awesome
right and so it's it's the training
yourself that as soon as you get an idea
you have
go off and do something about it right
so that's that's what you guys have here
like the first saying after you come up
with these gold these bold omissions for
yourself
most people default to planning mode
right you plan in your strategize you
think you ponder you research it's the
smart safe thing to do you plan and then
you wake up tomorrow a different person
and the whole thing is gone you will
wake up tomorrow a different person
you're in a high energy state you're
feeling bold confident amazing about
yourself you're just not living there
enough and then you come up with a goal
the next day you wake up a different
person and you find all the reasons why
you can't do that thing anymore
right you want help a billion people
great you're gonna wake up tomorrow like
I can't help I'm killing people come on
and then just go on with the rest of
your life right so you spend one percent
of our life living in that bold state
and 99 percent talking ourselves down
from it and so the first step is action
as soon as you set a goal for yourself
the very first thing is action and so
trust that that idea comes from
somewhere all right I believe you have
an idea it comes from somewhere it's
given to you right it comes from
somewhere you have to do something with
it even when it doesn't make sense
because new ideas won't make sense
because they're not logical you're
creating something new that's not
logical so as soon as you get an idea
trust that that idea is actually good
for you and then go do something about
it when you start it won't be the
perfect first step the most important
thing is that you started and you did
something the benefits of having success
is you get drownded opportunity
I'm enjoying an opportunity I have more
opportunity than I know what to do with
and it's it's my own time it's is the
asset is the limitation now financing
can be a limitation but you can always
work around that it doesn't have to be
you finance and everything you know
always find other partners to help you
out if you really wanted to so time is
the asset I started writing my book my
next book on this tour as a result of
talking to all the people that I've met
at the at the various workshops I don't
have time to read a book like I'm not
even keeping up with my other stuff and
now I have to do this
right but I have to because they Thea
came to me so I'm doing it you need to
figure out how you have your actions map
to your ambitions so you have limited
time you and her at some point you have
to scale the team to have people
underneath you who you trust to be
managers to take over where is the best
use of your time should be the constant
question that you ask yourself every
week where is the best use of my time
spent this week and then you look at
your calendar of where you're gonna
spend your time and say if I did these
things what I moved closer to my goals
or not and including your time together
because if it's only business all the
time you're gonna fight and grow apart
we had to go to a different one the only
thing is is that normally I would I'm
like okay cool my problems were all late
on this but it's when these
opportunities in these windows close
because these are people who have been
in the business for you know ones 25 um
ones 35 years are you gonna regret it
once it's done and it's closed that
window or that opportunity probably
won't be open for another ten years
so it's like yes you can't just be
chasing opportunity though like it's
gotta feed into something else right
it's got a like you want to have 20
different Dairy Queen's because it
fulfills a different purpose for you but
but listen but maybe you should like why
not are you not like you're capable you
just have to decide to be resourceful
you have to decide to be resourceful
that you're capable of more what do I
tell myself when I went overwhelmed this
is just a warm-up I'm capable of more
and once you feel like you're capable of
more in that this is just a warm-up then
you get into the land of resourcefulness
and you'll figure it out whether it's
old partners or people who've worked for
you or friends or some other part of the
community that you can tie in to make it
happen why can't you have 20 Dairy Queen
even 20 it's not that big a number
maybe you're capable of it and with that
you can then have a much bigger impact
in your community you're just not
capable of doing it right now with the
team and infrastructure that you have
right now
but what is a balanced life look like
between you guys as well as having 50
different Dairy Queen franchises and
using that as an opportunity to she's
like oh my gosh for now but when you get
there you may have to change it you need
to start leveling up where you're
spending your time when you first
started I'm sure you're in the store and
doing everything but cleaning up and
doing the cash and everything and now
you've had some success and so you
you're scaling up is this the limits if
you capabilities right now well then why
can't you have a 50 stores unto you you
just need you need to build the
infrastructure because you're not going
to go and clean the floors you've just
decided that where you're at right now
that this is the limit this is just a
warm-up it's still frustrating you're
still growing but it's just a warm-up
for what you're capable of doing why
can't you have 50 different locations
the infrastructure looks way different
than what you're doing right now right I
started my thing with myself now we have
24 people on the team for me to do
something more I mean in a hundred the
way that I mentor and coach my team I
can't do it at a hundred people my time
was already being stretched across the
24 on my team so something would have to
shift but I know I'm capable of that so
I have to dive into it even though it's
unknown because this is just a warm-up
it's not overwhelming as soon as it's
overwhelming you start losing you start
shutting down and you feel like you
don't have capabilities or resourceful
nough seni more if you thought you could
do it you will find a way to do it and
not destroy your entire relationship at
the same time you just need to level up
where you're spending your time you're
spending your time on on not CEO of a
hundred person company or a hundred
store franchise system you're still
thinking as a guy who has five their
queen stores as long as you think that
way you'll stay that way and maybe
that's fine but then I have the ear my
mom who's like if you have the
capability you're the responsibility you
have the responsibility to do more
because if you're training people the
right way you're creating jobs creating
opportunities you're creating good for
the community you're training people
we're now your partners on how to build
successful businesses and if that's part
of why you do what you do then you then
you have to get bigger and I think
you're capable of boring I want five
more companies to come at the same time
tomorrow to you and I want you to change
your system to force you to do better
instead of taking these little tiny
small steps I want you to take leaps
making this amazing event happen in
Phoenix was not a solo effort so I want
to give a quick shout out to all the
people who helped me promote this event
[Music]
if you want to see the fire Q&A that
happened in San Diego go click the link
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there